in to some extent yes it wasn't that I
was homeless or anything but I wasn't I
wasn't guided I wasn't told what to do I
was given a lot of freedom and also a
lot of responsibilities so when i was 13
i went to live in london on my with
another family but out of out of my own
family and when i was 15 i left home to
go to college and then after year at
college I took some time off and
hitchhiked around Europe and then went
to live in Morocco with my boyfriend and
for each of these things they basically
said if you want to do it go ahead and
do it be responsible for what happens
and bless you so I was in a sense
encouraged but not not manipulated you
could call that neglect but it was it
was pretty benign
it was kind of I took it for granted and
then realized there was no way I could
compete with my mother and my father so
I kind of avoided it in college and
thought it would be a novelist and then
I became a business journalist but then
in the end I got back into technology
because it was the most interesting
thing to write a bit
you